it's been less than a week since the
corona virus reached Gaza but already
it's clear that the territory is
woefully under-equipped
to cope with the pandemic authorities
are doing what they can Gaza
municipality is organizing the cleaning
and sterilizing of the markets in an
attempt to prevent the spread of the
corona virus we're doing this despite
being short of facilities and equipment
it is our duty to try to prevent the
virus from spreading the UN has already
warned that the crumbling infrastructure
will not be up to the challenge basic
health care and sanitation it says are
simply inadequate members of the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad armed wing the
alkyds brigade taking to the streets not
to demonstrate or bully but to join the
effort to stop the virus from spreading
business too is contributing its
expertise this Gaza factory is producing
protective clothing for medical workers
to its own design we want to protect
ourselves and medical staff production
has reached around 1,000 suits so far
there are six factories working for us
mosques in the Palestinian territory
have closed while mass rallies planned
for next week along the border with
Israel have been canceled people in Gaza
are doing what they can to prepare for
the pandemic but they're poor amenities
and infrastructure mean it's likely to
hit them hard joining me now from Gaza
is Matias mala he's the director of the
United Nations Relief and Works Agency
for Palestinian refugees in Gaza it's
great to have you with us Matias so far
there are at least nine confirmed
infections in the Gaza Strip how would
you describe the situation there right
now good afternoon to you I would
describe the situation as one of a
mixture
of panic since the first two cases were
announced a couple of days ago and very
deep worried about what would happen if
there is an indigenous infection and a
serious outbreak as was evidence in your
report just now the hospital sector here
is woefully unprepared in many ways what
I've been told is for every hundred
patients who would get ill you would
need at least five intensive care unit
beds now there are sixty maximum in the
whole of the Gaza Strip so you can do
the math as soon as there are more than
1500 people also ill the hospitals would
simply not cope so that's one big
concern the other concern is that in
these crowded conditions you know with
812 people often sharing a 2-bedroom
apartment let's say it's extremely
challenging to implement the usual
measures being advised by the World
Health Organization like social
distancing and of course proper hygienic
conditions in terms of hand-washing and
so on is also a challenge at the best of
times
mattias Gaza has been blockaded for
years by Israel in Egypt of course how
might those countries respond for
example is there any talk of temporarily
lifting restrictions for humanitarian
reasons well there's a couple of things
to say about this number one there has
been over these last two or three weeks
since Corona reached the region let's
say a relatively pragmatic cooperation
with the Israeli authorities so the
goods we have needed to bring in for
hospitals and so on as united nations
they've allowed through they've also not
curtailed the movement of other goods we
run for example as Unruh a food
operation for over a million people so
more than 50 million 50 percent of
Gaza's population depend on food and of
course in a lockdown it's critical that
people have access to food so so far
that has not been blocked what has been
blocked his movement of
and that's understandable our worry is
and our appeal to Israel but also Egypt
as another neighboring country and the
international community is not to forget
Gaza it is understandable that with this
being a pandemic and war countries
including Israel in Egypt being affected
that the focus is at home trying to keep
one's own population self in healthy but
an outbreak in Gaza will also affect
Israel in Egypt and the last thing we
would want is a complete shutting of the
borders people need food and need other
materials for the hospital sector and so
forth
mattias we have less than 30 seconds but
I want to ask you this we know that the
key to slowing an outbreak is social
distancing is that even realistically
possible there it is really challenging
but we should never give up we've
learned from the Ebola crisis that also
happened in impoverished overcrowded
areas that social behavior change is
possible and we are doing what we can to
affect that really appreciate your being
with us Matias sessional a director of
the UN's Relief and Works Agency for
Palestinian refugees in Gaza thank you
so much thank you